[Musique]
par lech vient saluer monsieur incognito
monsieur cognito pièce pourquoi je
tenais dans ma mère vous appelez offre
luche jozami pendant des années grand
mère merci qui est milliard jusqu'à yade
d'en accepter ses cinquièmes un plaisir
pour moi dans votre nouveau livre c'est
une sorte de biographie en fait ou vous
retracer votre parcours votre arrivée en
amérique mais aussi votre carrière quel
souvenir gardez-vous de france ruche je
suis bien content j'avais fait ma fille
vient de médias cuisine et pardon je
m'excuse je m'appelle fanfreluches je ne
sais pas où j'ai entendu ce nom c'est
dans ma tête je ne savais pas tout
qu'est ce que ça veut dire mais j'aimais
comme ça sonnait elle l a toujours
évolué au début elle ne faisait à peu
près que dans celles ne parlait pas
comme moi je ne connais pas très bien
français et il a pris avec les danses de
plus que je parlais puis je commençais
les deux de ses comptes et vouloir y
entrer je lis un conte russe
ce casque à un débat qui a mis les pieds
ça veut dire l'histoire du pêcheur et
son petit poisson rouge
oui justement vous venez de le dire
lorsque vous êtes débarqué de la russie
pour venir ici en amérique vous ne
parliez ni anglais ni français
comment il avait appelé français comment
ça s'est passé
mais jamais un amoureux francophone
c'est comme ça que j'ai appris le
français qui revient via écouter le
petit chaperon rouge ainsi toi ici et
j'ai tout de suite aimé normal alors et
l'émir poète tout ça comment avez vous
réagi lorsque vous proposer le rôle de
grand maman passe partout aussi un moyen
je jouais beaucoup théâtre qui est noble
ça ne plaît pas beaucoup à perdre c'est
je pense que j'étais contente que
d'avoir quelque chose à jouer qui
veulent m'aider à vivre et mourir noyé
vous venez d'avoir 94 eur alors comment
vous voyez ça vous ai réunis je n'aime
pas ça je vois des gens courir jeudi
hors chanceux je dois dire que quand je
je travaille quand j'écris comme je
décide et je voulais tout ça j'oublie
c'était connu la même chose que comme se
tait quand j'avais 20 ans que faites
vous comprenez artistique parce que
visiblement vous écrira encore avant
tout nouveau livre que j'écris encore
jeu je suis en train d'écrire un texte
c5 et c'est ça qui ma raison de vivre je
pense aux là parce que j'ai pas d'enfant
je pense que c'est ça que je dois thème
puisque ça vient ça me
ça me parle c'est ce qui m'a par les
grands compositeurs qu'on joue encore
ils ne sont jamais retraités bac
adèle rénaux
lou
les grands artistes ligne d'action dans
la vie c'est la création
les gens qui prennent leur retraite
s'ils pensent que ce qu'ils faisaient
les intéresse pas et des voix il trouve
la vraie chose qui les intéresse
après en prenant la retraite
donc il commence à vivre à ce moment là
que mira gers callas merci beaucoup ça a
été un véritable plaisir si
[Musique]